[Music]
19g 40 days I got stabbed shots fired
body camera video shows the moments
leading up to a deadly officer-involved
shooting after a suspect stabs multiple
officers on the scene yeah no he got she
stabbed me yeah yeah
it happened on February 18th in Houston
Texas officers were dispatched for a
welfare check of John Kung Tran Lee who
was having a mental health crisis okay
so my brothers
you say he's safe he's mental so you
guys can't leave him here there's no
possible way we've been trying to get
him out try and help him but he's not
gonna leave body camera video shows
responding officers speaking with Lee's
brother who says he's dealt with mental
health issues in the past
so I don't know what you guys need to do
but you guys seem to take him get him
into a sideboard and we can handle the
recipe Lee's brother says he has been
struggling the past few days and was
progressively getting worse the last
couple days has been kind of proceeding
each day is kind of getting guided
around today is getting bad where he's
making my grandparents and my mom sit in
the living room not if they she took
their phones
I had to I'm I just kind of like had to
kind of sneak out here because I saw you
guys out here he tells officers he's
scared what will happen if his brother
sees him
he can't see me talk to him either
because he's going to hold the girls
against me just follow me I don't know
what he's gonna be capable of right he's
just crazy Lee's brother also says he
had other mental health related
incidents he took any kind of medication
right now I don't know anything right
now but currently I know that he's just
not in his right mind but I can't does
he work on the coast does he work does
he work or no uh no he hasn't been able
to work because of
[Music]
you see on medications no eventually
officers approached the house where Lee
is staying you might want to say that
and wait for us
Lee answers the door but cannot be seen
on the body camera video audio captures
his conversation with officers
hello
[Music]
hi is this yourself
can you talk right here okay can I see
you and when I see who you are I want to
make sure that you have nothing you have
any weapon on you I have nothing okay
officers ask whether Lee wants to be
taken to the hospital
what's going on John
do you want to go hospital
isn't anybody inside the house beside
you
oh my family your family can I talk to
your mom is your mom home
after that officers speak with a woman
who's presumed to be Lee's mother she
tells officers trouble could be on the
way
hello
the Houston Police Department did not
release the body camera from inside
Lee's home saying video taken in a
private space cannot publicly be shared
without written permission the next
portion of the video shows the aftermath
of the officer-involved shooting
[Music]
19g 40 days I got stabbed shots fired
investigators say Lee stabbed both
responding officers after that one of
the officers opened fire hitting Lee
where's suspect at he's sitting inside
so I can sit on the floor he got shot
too I shot him video then shows officers
scrambling to get first aid equipment as
blood smears over the body camera let me
apply pressure
that's your night right
sorry yeah you have my hands feeling now
but uh
okay you want you want to apply pressure
on your neck right now apply fresh on
your neck you sit down in the car stay
once both officers were taken to the
hospital for their injuries and later
released Lee died as a result of the
shooting right now the shooting is still
in the early stages of the investigation
Houston officials say evidence is still
being collected and Witnesses are still
being interviewed reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie